this is Tuesday November 8th the day of
the 2016 presidential election between
Secretary Clinton representing the
Democrats and Donald Trump representing
national suicide and this is the closer
the calendar says 2016 but for all
intents and purposes this might as well
be November 8th 1864 because not since
that day exactly 152 years ago have we
Americans voted on whether or not to put
ourselves out of existence for all the
existential national crises of the
intervening century and a half since
Abraham Lincoln was reelected none of
those moments when the United States of
America could have perished included
national suicide that's how deadly
serious today is go forward with Hillary
Clinton who at the worst will be a good
president hamstrung by an obstructionist
Congress and the same kind of clutched
pearls nonsensical investigations that
hindered but never came close to
defeating her husband or put the full
power of the government into the hands
of an overwrought child an amateur who
believes he is God's gift to mankind and
always had too much money to be impacted
by his own failures a sadistic bully
with a cult but not a clue who indeed
can be baited by a tweet who spent much
of the last three days of his campaign
even this morning complaining about
Beyonce and jay-z and apparently making
up stories about Tom Brady having voted
for him and on to whom 40% or more of
this country has projected its personal
grievances and prejudices and fears and
many of whom support him because of
blinding and ill-timed party loyalty
stock markets will crash the world
balance of power will be ruined before
the inauguration Russia's influence will
immediately double the Constitution's
guarantees will become coin flips and
the lifeblood of this country since
before its founding immigration will be
spilled metaphorically or otherwise on
our streets all because of the ego of
one American and the incapability of
tens of millions of other Americans to
understand that all they like and love
about our country can vanish nearly
overnight that a vote to burn it all
down does not just mean the purge they
want a minority
and immigrants in the media and anybody
else they want to blame but it also
means that their America burns that
their homes burn that their possessions
burn that the futures of their children
burn
that's how deadly serious today is most
Americans who know our history think of
the 1860 presidential election as the
last one that chose life or death for
the country
the famous senator Stephen a Douglas
Tennessee Senator John Bell vice
president John Breckinridge who was
pro-slavery against an obscure ex
congressman from Illinois named Abraham
Lincoln Lincoln to whom at Raleigh North
Carolina yesterday Donald Trump compared
himself boasting he got more Republican
primary votes than did Lincoln even
though the population in 1860 was 1/10
of what it is today even though there
were no Republican primaries in 1860
quote I got more than honest Abe tens of
millions of people will actually vote
for this diseased narcissist today
anyway the 1860 vote was crucial but
civil war was likely despite the outcome
it was the 1864
election 152 years ago today that was
life or death as late as August of that
year some Republicans were talking about
holding a second convention withdrawing
their reen AMA nation of President
Lincoln and finding somebody else they
and the leadership and Lincoln himself
were convinced that as things stood
Lincoln would not be reelected and would
lose to the Democratic candidate George
McClellan McClellan was the general who
had nearly lost the Civil War to the
South had been twice replaced and was
now running on a democratic platform of
immediately ending the war negotiating a
settlement of any kind with the south
and repudiating the Emancipation
Proclamation which had just Fried's
three million Americans from slavery
barely eighteen months before and it was
believed nationwide that Lincoln was
going to lose to him in a landslide and
then on September 2nd 1864 the Union
Army led by General William Tecumseh
Sherman took Atlanta at which point
north and south the outcome of the Civil
War became a foregone conclusion the
political fortunes of Lincoln and
McClellan
changed violently obviously 152 years
ago today Abraham Lincoln was reelected
by 212 electoral college votes to
McClellan's 21 votes the tragic war was
seen through to its conclusion slavery
was not restored the United States of
America was not split into the nation
did not commit suicide and yet in the
popular vote nearly all of it from only
the northern states 45% of our ancestors
still voted against Lincoln voted
against finishing the war they were
winning voted against freeing the slaves
voted for national suicide 45% that's
how deadly serious today is there have
been other moments when democracy could
have died the revolution itself the
British burning of Washington in 1814
the Civil War obviously especially at
Gettysburg where Lincoln later became
immortal where Trump threatened to file
vengeance lawsuits the Great Depression
and the prospect of a full-on communist
revolution here or a full-on right-wing
military coup both world wars the Cuban
Missile Crisis Watergate 9/11 and the
proposal by one elected official that in
the aftermath of Terror the end of his
term should be delayed by three months
that elected official was of course the
then mayor of New York City Rudy
Giuliani the democracy the country are
more fragile and have faced more perils
than most of us ever choose to admit but
nearly always these perils have been
external and have unified us have not
been the result of a kind of cancer not
merely growing from within the country
but fed and fuelled and nurtured and
exploited by a psychopathic liar who has
gamed democracy and is still this very
day positioned to destroy democracy by
means of the very freedoms it provides
freedoms which he would happily and
immediately extinguish that's how deadly
serious today is each life-or-death
moment in our 240 years as the closest
thing to true freedom in the history of
this planet has been met with courage
and wisdom and unity and especially
sacrifice the likes of which few of us
personally know or can truly imagine and
in none of them not the British Invasion
not the Civil War not the deprived
World War 1 World War 2 not the Cuban
Missile Crisis not Watergate not 9/11
where we afford it it's such an easy
means of escape such a simple method of
protection as rests in every man and
every woman in every voting booth in
every community in this country today we
do not have to go to war we do not have
to force a president from office we do
not have to forestall a revolution we do
not have to keep nuclear missiles from
flying we do not have to recover from
terrorism the Trump crisis of 2016
national suicide the death of the United
States of America can be prevented by
voting
that's how deadly serious today is
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space